a couple times he's terrific you may
have seen him on Last Comic Standing
everybody give a big round of applause
for mark Normand everybody all right I'm
kind of a smaller version of the last
guy hello everyone hello a lot of
attractive ladies here hello how are you
I like an attractive lady which is
interesting because when I was a kid I
hated girls when I was like six years
old I thought girls were gross thought
they were dumb hey you know you're a lot
of to hate girls as a kid that's really
the only group of kids allowed to hate
because if I was a six-year-old it hated
Porto Ricans that would be weird-looking
it was like hey mom I need Porto Ricans
you would never say oh you'll like him
one day no like on the lot
any Puerto Ricans here all right so be
good show just getting a little bit 40
good people I live in the city I had
some friends visit me recently a real
crazy guys like to get laid get nasty
get Nick and salami all the type of guys
who do this a lot does anyone else have
that one friend where you go out to a
bar to try to meet girls and like 20
minutes into it they just go screw this
let's go to a strip club I don't get
that lunch you know to me that's like
going fishing not catching anything if
you'd like screw of this let's go to the
aquarium
it's the same thing I got I'm not a big
strip club guy now the strippers are
just a big tease to be like I look at
strippers the same I look at fire alarms
and I'm like oh man I really won such
that I know if I do love to leave the
building
hi do like they have a sauce pretty hard
going to boozehound I was at a bar the
other night and there were a couple
girls at the bar flirting with guys just
for the free drinks they weren't going
to put out they won those drinks pretty
good move makes you wonder you think
there's ever been these smart kids out
there who would flirt with pedophiles
just for the candy hey Timmy I'm suck
that guy he's a child molester I don't
wanna feel it gotta get these skills
somehow I'll tell you those pedophiles
are a creepy Bunch
I'm creepy bunch of guys Creek is a fun
word though and because it's a word
that's changed ladies to a kid to adult
any corners and things like to a kid
creepy is like spooky like a cemetery is
creepy to an adult creepy is like a guy
on a bus who winks at you a little bit
I'm actually the creepy guy at my office
I work as a janitor during the day I
tell people on a maintenance man but
this mopping hate my job it's the worst
job overhead everybody looks down me
they talk down on me the other day I was
mopping the floor and a businessman
slipped and he goes come on man if the
floor is wet we got to put a sign down
I'm like I'm mopping in front of you
I am the side
no one got on the side doing this that's
me but in 3d come on my boss chew me out
ever he's like come on mark you're
embarrassing me out there like well that
makes two of us I'm a janitor one perk
one perk of being a janitor is I work a
lot of ex-cons and they tell me stories
of jail and they are horrific stories of
prison you're not a hole drop the soap
in prison that is real that's a real
thing don't you think about time in
prison showers we get some body washing
would help a lot of people out of a web
I dropped a little I'll just get another
squirt back it up back it up I'm not
bending over
that's me body washes whole new ad
campaign by Old Spice it'll save your
ass
somebody recently told me that that joke
was homophobic
and if being scared of getting anally
raped makes me unloaded I'll tell you
there's a gay guy at my work I like the
gays we're good buddies a good gay
appeal I've been told does a gay guy my
work and I'm all for gay marriage I love
gay marriage because it's the only big
issue you can be honest about and still
looks like a good person let me explain
like I said I says hey man how do you
feel about the earthquake in Haiti I
don't care that affect me what a dick
what if somebody says hey man how do you
feel about gays getting married
I don't care doesn't affect me you got
the right attitude
I have a good friend that he is gotta be
gay like I'm positive he's gave a 100%
positive he's gay but he won't admit you
know I don't care that he's game just
tell me we're friends the most like
Kannada when it'll say well I
experimented in college and I'm like
yeah but you went to college online
never done college online it's like 20
minutes a month you know so really you
are gay and you experimented with
college that's what really happened
there I love the gays I want my friends
just moved up here and he's kind of new
he's kind of behind the times and every
time he talked about a gay person he
says this he goes uh yeah you know my
friend Jeff he's gay good guy though
every time he's gay a good guy though
which is weird
his gays aren't even known for being bad
people you know it seemed you're like oh
you know my friend Jeff he's a pedophile
good guy though that makes sense but
that's not even a stereotype the gays
are bad you know no one's ever like a
man hide your wallet there's gays around
religious people don't like the gays
that's a thing I'm not religious I've
never lived at all although I do find
religion funny like it's actually have
it in the 50s rock and roll considered
the devil's music
now this Christian rock what they'll
happen there I guess Christians go ahead
old motto if you can't beat them ruin it
I think my favorite look is gotta be
Scientology sign top
all right let's make fun of them I love
science all because it's the only
religion out there you can make fun of
in public and everybody's on board
religion such a touchy subject you can
never do that with any other group you
know you can never be like like if
you're like man I hate the Muslims or
you're a racist like the Jews we're
going to test at night white
Scientologists what are you doing later
any Jews here all right comp in juice I
like that don't why you put your dukes
up that's weird
all right
he must be from Brooklyn I love a good
Jew I love Jews I like Jews cuz you guys
have your own persona you don't
personality you know so much so you
can't use the word Jew as an adjective
you be like oh yeah Jeff's got curly
hair very nervous kind of Julie but you
could never do that with any other
religion you know you're gonna be like
wait a Bob you all his wife drives kind
of Lizzie makes your cover face biggle
does that buddy of Mines a real big
sports fan
he was bummed out the other day because
his a favorite baseball player is on
steroids and I was like what do you care
anyway saying how would you feel if your
favorite porn star was on viagra
and I was like well honestly I think
it's strange you take my favorite porn
star that man
a lot of care porn stars one by a girl I
care for on steroids
that's great you know I'm not watching
porn for the ethics I love I love the
Internet that's my religion I feel like
if I have a religion it's the Internet
I'm on it all day I give it money that's
my religion that's why I love my
neighborhood he's ever around me has
Wi-Fi restaurants coffee shops I saw a
guy bar with Wi-Fi the other day the
only place I've never seen with Wi-Fi is
a church and I think that makes sense
because no church once compete with a
difficult hour that actually works
Vegas race is a touchy subject let's
talk about that I got in trouble to
comedy show recently because I used a
racial slur but I did win owes a slur I
had no idea but in my defense
can we all agree that the gentlest of
the racial slurs has got to be [ __ ]
Ronny come on he's from China he's a man
not so bad - making the names of Chinese
restaurants actually sound a lot more
like racial slurs let's try something
you know can't drive those frickin panda
cakes I can I Drive it off
and listen to this one of those golden
doodles just learn my apartment building
right next door be there one big happy
family
all right I can do that joke a friend's
an Asian an explanation good guy
race is such a ridiculous thing to get
mad about you know it's such a touchy
thing everybody gets so crazy about race
like I think sometimes calling stuff on
races can in fact be more racist I'll
give an example how's that a restaurant
recently guy came in to get a takeout
order they screwed up his order like
five times
eventually guy just snaps he goes Jesus
what is this place run by monkeys and
the manager goes excuse me sir that is
racist now it is I was at a party
recently and this guy comes up me out of
the blue and he goes Han you ever dated
a spanish girl I was like I don't think
so and he goes you have my Spanish
friends do you
I was like no I don't have a white
friends either you rub it in like why do
we always jump right to racism you know
it's always like you only black friends
you must hate black people so I'm just
unpleasant to be around I kill for some
black friends I cook with some white
friends I'm very long
a Spanish man before I am I I'm seeing a
lady right now the lights are you on joy
I don't know wait for an answer there
got nothing yeah it's not going too well
God's up from the girlfriend last night
I haven't got any ears got the old blue
balls doesn't thought about that but
hate the blue balls the worst part about
like what is it with blue balls I don't
get it what is that peach funny to me
what is it and the only way to explain
it to her the only way I could make her
get it was by saying hey gee
referenceusa now I can't see she was
like whoa whoa whatever Susan look I
can't like what you can't just start it
up now just like look I can't she's like
please please don't do anything like
that
blue balls right there sister what a
good thing about the relationship is me
and my girlfriend are both terrible
infinite so we get along and I caught
her reading a Cosmo recently I look over
shoulder it says please your man
invented by giving him compliments I was
like all right is gonna be great next
time we have said she's going to be
complimenting me what she did what the
compliments weren't sexy so it's just
awkward I'll give an example we're going
at it and I flip her over she goes good
idea
then I get something else she goes
nicely done
and I'll tell you a kiddy compliments in
bed sounded good in theory but you never
want to be in a sexual situation with a
woman ever say not too shabby
little bill creepy thanks a lot guys